[Music]
it's a common question many of you may
have
where can women go to get a mammogram
for free or at little cost today denise
valdez shows us one of the best ways
because it's a service that rolls right
into your
neighborhood many women are either
uninsured or underinsured right now but
remember mammograms are preventative
screenings so they're covered by
insurance but if you're still concerned
about cost one of the best resources to
get a low-cost mammogram is through the
mama van it's actually an imaging van
think about it on wheels so i'm going to
walk you through and show you how easy
it is to make an appointment so this is
the home page here for
nevadahealthcenters.org
what you're going to do is go over here
to services let it load up then go over
here to mammography again this is all to
make your appointment and to do your
your um
uh your paperwork all right so remember
this is the big pink bus right this is
the one that travels all across the
state so to find out where it's going to
be we're going to go to the calendar
we're going to scroll up
hit your calendar and it only loads one
month at a time so we're going to take a
look at february and this way you can
find out where the mama van is going to
be in your part of the state so right
now here we are this week i'm going to
try and make this a little bit bigger
for us there we go this week they're
actually all up in northern california i
should say northern nevada then we come
out here the following week they're
going to be in las vegas they're going
to be all the way out through north las
vegas the following week to head out to
laughlin before they actually end their
week in henderson so there's also a
toll-free number on here to make an
appointment and a way to print out that
paperwork i was talking about a minute
ago so depending on your financial
status some mammograms can actually be
free but certainly these are going to be
low cost through the mama ban now
there's onboard imaging equipment just
like you would see anywhere else the
mama van has been serving nevada for
more than 20 years and it sees nearly 3
000 women a year so when they roll into
your community it's really a great way
to take advantage of that low-cost
screening and according to the national
breast cancer foundation one in eight
women will be diagnosed with breast
cancer in their lifetime but it's also
the most preventable and the mamma ban
makes it an easy way to get that done
for buddy check i'm denise valdez back
to you